[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute habe ich mal
wieder was mit rios für euch ich liebe
ja bloß das wisst ihr wer nämlich schon
länger verfolgt und deshalb habe ich für
euch ein orio tiramisu kreiert falls
jetzt auch wissen möchte wie man ganz
unkompliziert dieses leckere bisher nach
macht dann bleib jetzt einfach dran
wir starten mit der ersten schicht und
zwar den boden dafür benötigen wir zwei
packungen orio das sind 360 gramm sowie
130 gramm geschmolzene butter
ich gebe die urus in meinen zerkleinerer
und mixe das ganze dann fein ihr könnt
das allerdings auch in einen
gefrierbeutel tun und damit einem
nudelholz drauf köpfen das geht auch
sobald die uhr ist dann schön fein sind
nehmen wir den deckel ab und geben die
butter mit hinzu
die mutter sollte dann zusammen mit den
urus eine kompakte masse ergäben
nun nehme ich mir meine auflaufform denn
darin werde ich das orion tiramisu und
schichten und gebe dafür den boden
hinein
nachdem der orior bodenlärm schön flach
an gedrückt wurde geben wir die
auflaufform bis zur weiterverarbeitung
in den kühlschrank für die creme
benötigen wir 600 gramm kalte
schlagsahne 500 gramm mascarpone drei
packungen seine steif für die sahne
sowie zwei packungen seine stadt für die
mascarpone und zum süßen 40 gramm
puderzucker sowie 20 gramm vanillezucker
zuallererst wird die sahne steif
geschlagen und wichtig ist dass die
sonne direkt aus dem kühlschrank kommt
so lässt sich wirklich wunderbar steif
schlagen hier gebe ich noch dass seine
stadt mit hinzu ihr könntet alternativ
auch sechs teelöffel so apart verwenden
die steif geschlagene sahne gebe ich
dann bis zur weiterverarbeitung in den
kühlschrank auch wenn es nur ein paar
minuten sind und mache dann weiter mit
der maske ohne creme
hierfür gebe ich mascarpone puderzucker
und verbindet so kann eine schüssel und
vermisste das ganz kurz miteinander bis
sich dann bis sahnesteif mit hinzu gebe
dann noch einmal ganz kurz miteinander
vermischten und schon kommt wieder und
susanne zum einsatz
die sahne heben wir dann noch mit einem
teig darunter und sobald alles schön
miteinander verbunden ist ist unsere
creme auch schon fertig
auch die gebe ich jetzt bis zur
weiterverarbeitung in den kühlschrank
und mach weiter mit der schokosoße
hierfür benötigen wir 150 milliliter
schlagsahne zweieinhalb esslöffel ba
kakao und 3 1 ab ist er viel puderzucker
und die drei zutaten werden jetzt ganz
einfach miteinander verrührt sobald dann
die zutaten schön klümpchen frei
verrührt wurden ist eure blitzschnelle
schokosoße auch schon fertig jetzt
müssen wir nur noch alles miteinander
schichten und dafür nehme ich
zuallererst die auflaufform aus dem
kühlschrank und gebe dort die hälfte
meiner mascarpone sahne creme drauf
nachdem sie dann schön glaubt
verstrichen wurde das muss auch nicht so
genau sein geben wir die hälfte der
schokosoße drauf
auf die glatt gestrichene schokosoße
kommt nun die zweite hälfte der maske ab
ohne sahne creme und wird noch einmal
glatt verstrichen
auch diese schoko schicht wird nun glatt
verstrichen und dann ist das orale
therapie so auch schon fast fertig
zum krönenden abschluss gebe ich auf das
tiramisu noch ein wenig bei kakao drauf
und da könnt ihr natürlich auch
dekorieren wie ihr möchtet
[Musik]
das orion ist er ist jetzt auch schon
fertig und ihr könnt es im prinzip
sofort servieren keine unnötig lange
wartezeiten oder kühl zeiten ihr könnt
sofort anschneiden und genießen haltbar
ist das ganze bis zu drei tage
allerdings hält das ganze sowieso nicht
so lange weil es einfach so lecker ist
es bei einem stück meistens nicht bleibt
alle zutaten stehen wie immer unten in
der infobox und falls ihr keines meiner
videos mehr verpassen möchte dann lassen
wir doch gerne ein abo da bis zum
nächsten mal tschüss